all right all right guys
we are live we're doing this
you guys know how it is every single
saturday at 10
45 a.m pacific standard time
we're doing vfx live streams the whole
point of this is to get a community
together
and to get excited about vfx and to get
excited
to get excited about 3d and to get
excited about working together and
learning and growing together that's the
whole point of this right now
is exactly that if you guys can hear me
if you can see me just give me a little
thumbs up so i know we're good
um this is going to be exciting this is
very exciting i've been live streaming
over the last
year and this is the first time i
actually
got stream upgrades now um so that means
i got a bunch of different scenes and
you know a bunch of you know
announcements and whatnot
um and alerts and crap it's all it's
gonna be cool hopefully it's a nice
little touch
i'm still working on it but guys if
you're uh if you're joining me live or
if you're watching this after the fact
um what are we doing we're creating
we're recreating a photo today and
actually i should have that photo queued
up
i don't let me see if i can pull it up
real quick um
let's pull up this photo so it is a
night city
scene let's see here
let's pop these references boom
so oh also yeah i got a switch
bam here we go okay so for this
basically
we uh we went up myself ran uh nico
and a bunch of other guys one wheeled up
to this mountain
and we're overlooking i think this is
burbank
and i thought this was such a cool shot
that ren took
and this is me standing here looking
down at burbank and i'm like i would
love to recreate this
in 3d so that's exactly what we're doing
here today the point is
we're not we're not trying to go in and
create every building
because that's going to take forever and
it's also going to tax our system like
crazy
so we got to be real smart about how we
make this
and that's exactly what this is about
today so
um let's hop in and do this
i'm very excited all right so first
we're starting off
in after effects actually
um and we're going what we're going to
do is we're going to make a displacement
map
that we can use in octane as a texture
displacement
so black values go down white values get
pushed
up and we're going to kind of mimic
this look of you know of city buildings
here
now that is what's called a grebel
effect
um you can google grebel but basically
it's just like
a blocky qb texture across a large
area that's called grebel if you guys
are familiar with
any of the star wars spaceships um
especially in the original trilogy
you'll know that like the death star
it's gribbled out it's got a bunch of qb
blocky texture all across the whole
thing
um so that's what we're going to do and
we're going to create that in after
effects and it's very
very simple um
so anyway hey guys shout outs to
everyone joining me live here this is
awesome
uh fruit juice i see you man thanks for
coming to these uh these live streams
and competing in the weekly challenge i
really think that's cool your renders
have been awesome uh
tinum what's going on good to see you
again
got a lot of familiar faces guys thank
you so much for joining me
geppy i'm glad that you liked my render
it was cool i had a good time making it
um for any of you guys who are new to my
channel
uh welcome welcome let's have some fun
let's create some stuff all right
so first thing learn your shortcuts
control y will get you a solid
all right so we want to make a solid it
doesn't matter what color it is
and on that solid we want to throw on an
effect called
fractal uh fractal noise
it's under noise and grain you can use
the little search bar here
if you have your layer selected you can
double click and the effect
will be pasted right on top of your
solid there
so from here what we want to do is we
want to make
a bunch of blocky black and white cubes
so the easiest way that i can think to
do that is actually with
mosaic so i'm going to make a new layer
an adjustment layer the the hotkey is
ctrl
alt ctrl alt y yeah ctrl alt y
and we'll look for mosaic
double-click to throw it on there bam
you see how that
that like blocks it out you know but
let's make it a little larger let's go
like
30 by 30.
and heck let's go 40 let's go 40 by 40.
let's give us a bit more resolution and
by the way if you hit ctrl k in your
composition settings you'll see
that uh i'm at a 40 96 by 4096 and that
is 4k resolution so this is like a
seamless 4k texture if you will right
the frame rate doesn't matter because
we're just looking for an image it's
just a picture
so let's go ahead and cancel that
now we want to control
the amount of contrast so the the darker
these blacks are and the wider these
whites are the further
our displacement map will be pushed in
octane or you know if you guys are using
blender cycles whatever like it really
doesn't matter what program you're using
you can do this in anything any program
you guys want
so that's no problem at all
all right so from here
what we can do is we can add like a
levels to this and we can also add
like a gradient in octane so you don't
have to go too insane with this
but we just kind of want to bring
these levels up just so it's a little
bit
a little bit more contrasty a bit more
punchy and let's just try
saving this out as a jpeg so i'm going
to make sure
that the duration here is just one frame
that way when i hit ctrl shift backspace
it goes to the render queue you can go
composition
add to render queue if you want um and
let's just save this out as a jpeg
sequence
since it's one frame um it's just gonna
be one frame
boom boom all right so now
if we're in cinema let's see what we can
do let me switch over my stream setup
for y'all so you can see what's going on
awesome awesome all right
so how do we use that image that we just
created let's make a plane
whether you're in blender or c4d or 3ds
max or maya you can make a plane
and let's go ahead and render our view
here
we got a plane and let's go ahead and
save
what the heck we're doing okay because
you do not want to lose your crap all
right it happens and it sucks
so make sure your stuff is organized
and named properly so let's just call
this uh
night city and one a
i learned this one a business from chris
schmidt over at rocket lasso
um basically saving iterations so i can
always come back to a previous state
i'm never overriding the same file so
i'll do a 1b a 1c etc
bam alright so from here
let's go ahead let's just load an hdri
for fun
because it looks nice so i'm just going
to make an octane sky which you can do
by going to
let's see objects hdri environment
you can also do this in blender i forget
exactly how but i've been i've been
following some blender tutorials i've
been doing some blender guru some peter
france
um it's really fun it's really fun
um kids is asking why don't you use the
built-in cell noise of c4d probably
better way to do it
i'm not gonna lie not gonna lie
anyway let's move on i'll mess with that
in a second we'll see about that
let's go ahead and load this in i'm
gonna click this image and let's load up
in hdri
i got some good hdr haven hdris which
i mean dude they're they're the best
there's no getting around it guys
they're the best
let's get an outdoor one just to spice
things
up a little bit bam cloudy load that in
we looking nice okay so um if you notice
this comes in blown out i'ma fix it in a
second and i'll show you what i mean
because we got to get some detail in
here first here what if i just you know
make a cube you see how blown out it is
it looks nasty
that's because our hdr environment if
you click it you need to set the color
profile to linear
and then it'll uh it'll even itself out
there but let's go ahead and apply this
mosaic effect
and uh drop it on our plane here so i'm
gonna make
a a glossy material why not let's make a
glossy material
we'll drop it on and these materials are
being spawned right over my head
just down here and you're getting some
materials down the line here
which you can see if i pop this out
there it is
um so i'm a double click it i always
work in node view because it's like
it's just way faster you're actually
able to see
like what the heck's going on so we'll
go to node editor
and usually i like to dock this for some
reason
this docking mess kind of gets
there's like the glitch with octane or
something it does this whatever
displacement that's what we want
displacement so let's
make a displacement node and let's drag
that texture and look for an
image texture and the image the image
texture is going to be the thing
that we exported from after effects
where are you did i even name it
where what where the heck did i save it
it is white this is why you all got to
be organized duplicate
the thing go in it's on my desktop
but it says it's not on my desktop
oh cause it's in a folder called comp
one confusing
all right anyway we'll load that in and
boom
automatically look you can see it's
doing something
all right let's um let's make some
adjustments
okay first i'm gonna go and uh if you're
if you're an octane
or if you're in blender whatever you got
a camera and hopefully you got some
camera options this is my camera tag
you can right click it and go to c4d
tags add a camera tag
and basically from here camera imager if
you check that box
um let's just pull up like a portrait
400
go down to one so we'll crank the
highlight compression too that way we
can see what's going a little bit more
and if you look closely you can see this
weird stepping going on and we don't
want that so that's just because our
resolution is low
so with the displacement node selected
you can set the level of detail
to 4k because that's what we made the
image in and you can see automatically
it's looking nicer
it still has some weird stepping stuff
that's not an issue for us right now
you can definitely try and blur it a
little bit
and that will help it do a little filter
type gaussian
filter radius one and then actually
clean things up a little bit so
i'm happy with that mid level always 0.5
that'll uh
even things out basically um instead of
your black values not moving your black
values will actually go down
your gray values will stay level and
your white values will go up
hopefully that makes sense to y'all
um yes scuka mirrors edge vibes
yeah for sure that game was amazing i
freaking
loved it so much
alright alright alright so
from here what are we doing
what are we doing from here guys we're
going to push our values height 10
nah 30 son let's go whoa
okay not 3 000. um not 3 000.
that is a different day different
tutorial but that looks freaking cool
doesn't it
doesn't that look sick you get some fog
going in here
like that's some freaking ice caves
get a nice little like specular thing
going there
little big planet vibes all right but
that's not like i said that's not today
um
let's adjust that displacement map
30 sun boom all right so now
it's a little bit more pronounced let's
take the value
the diffuse value to just a gray
that way we're actually able to see
something and let me i'm actually going
to change
my hdri again to an indoor one
a light old hall
let's give it a shot yeah i think that's
just a little bit nicer you know like
we're actually able to see what's going
on we can adjust
just just because this has nothing to do
with the tutorial roughness let's go 0.2
and you just kind of even out those
those specular highlights a little bit
that looks pretty sweet
so this is going to be the basis of our
city
that we're viewing from this mountain
right
uh marthal arts yeah dude almost 400 sun
what up everybody
yeah when i started this thing it was
around like 150
um so it's been cool it's been cool and
it's been very satisfying doing this
every single week
and speaking of satisfying oscar c i see
you
i'm glad you guys liked my satisfying
instagram post
the render that we did for corridor it
was a blast i can't wait to do it again
uh we got some we got a special guest
coming in next week
i can't say anything yet but boy is
going to be fun
boy it will be fun all right let's keep
moving
so let's go ahead and clone this thing
right so
let's take the plane um hold alt and pop
it in a cloner and i'm always going to
set the instance to multi-instance that
way it
you can clone a lot more things without
taxing your system let's open this up
something like that is totally fine and
you can't even tell that it's looping
let's try and take it i don't know
ten by ten and we got this giant city
mass
now it'd be nice to have some larger
detail going on here like this is kind
of like a base layer of detail
if i go in like let's say we want to
have some buildings
popping off at like 100 centimeters you
know
um versus just the 30. so here's
what you can do you can do you can do
this a lot of different ways
but let's give this a shot i'm going to
hold ctrl and make a new
material and let's take that new
material
and let's actually let's take the gamma
of this noise uh this little noise map
we made
if i solo it okay you can't see it but
let's let's take the gamma to like five
so it really makes it contrast
you see that you can even go to six
you know whatever and it's just gonna
make it nice and contrasty
and we'll set uh we'll just duplicate
the plane
in our cloner and we'll drag the new
material on there
and you should see it update here
oh maybe it's really subtle so here's
what i'll do i'll go into the
displacement
and let's set the height to like 120.
there you go so now you can see it's
displacing these two different materials
across these planes here which by the
way you can set the width and height
segments
to for again just one and you're still
going to get the same amount of detail
because it's a texture displacement
not a vertex displacement a vertex
displacement requires
like mesh data in order to make things
look high-res
so if i were to hit n and then b you can
clearly see
that there aren't you know this is just
one plane
with no subdivisions
that's the beauty of this i think octane
does this really well you can set this
to 20 by 20 but you
you're not going to get any difference
in this your the only difference
is your pc is going to chug a little bit
harder all right so
the point of this video is how to do it
without blowing up your computer and
that's one of the ways we're doing this
take down those polygons keep the detail
all right caleb's like what the heck
so you can get some really cool vibes
like this you know like let's make a
third one let's let's duplicate it
let's do um let's go in here
and let's go to our node view let's take
this let's go
transform can we transform this let's do
let's make a new plane ctrl drag keeping
it in the cloner
drag your new material on there
which it can get confusing just know the
third one is
the third one all right we got three
materials three different planes i think
it makes sense to y'all
um let's take the gamma
up to like eight freaking eight son
and then let's even
let's see if we can do this can we do a
color correction node
on here and crank the contrast
is that gonna work and let's do a
texture displacement
let's go 500 and see
what happens all right
yo y'all with the super chats heck yeah
one day duck thank you sir mark henry
thank you sir
for the super chat heck yeah
very very cool so i'm trying to get the
alerts going here so when you guys do
the super chat
comes up on the stream as
you know like a sweet little like
alert thing might have to
i don't know maybe it's working maybe
it's not
but we'll see i'm gonna keep working on
it but thank you all regardless for
those super chats that's awesome
keep up the good work thanks for coming
back y'all are awesome
okay nelay
hello my friend william
heck yeah all right let's do it yo it's
ren
it's freaking wren y'all
richie thank you thank you for the super
chat brandon what's good son
what's up what's up son yo we're doing
it man we're freaking
doing it all right we're deep in it
right now look at this
ren was the one who told me about octane
the man the myth the legend um and if it
wasn't for ren
i wouldn't be popping off some sweet
renders right now so definitely give him
a shout out
so we have this one
plane and
it's displaying nothing because our
contrast is too high
so we need to bring our contrast back
down
in order for it to read um let's set the
contrast back to zero
and figure out why this isn't working i
think it's because i have a color
correction node in between
yeah that's not working so maybe the
power comes down or something
i just want to get some variation in
here let me save an iteration
i don't know why you can't like uh
why you can't add color correction nodes
to this stuff it's kind of annoying what
if i invert it
let's set the power to one
what happens in that case
let me refresh my render
mr samuel gindert
thank you sir for the very generous
super chat
um he says hey what do you think about
c4d versus 3ds max is it just personal
preference or do you think c4d is
superior great
question fantastic question um
i don't think one program is better than
another i think it's all about what you
create in that program so don't get hung
up on specific program stuff i know a
lot of you guys
ren's like 3ds max we use 3ds max for
like six years straight so no worries
um it really just depends on what you
can create in the program
there's no superiority with anything
blender versus c4d or versus 3ds max
versus maya
just it's what you can create so don't
get hung up on the programs y'all
don't worry about that stuff just have a
good time with what you're creating
that's it
that's the whole point okay
so it looks like we have a couple
different
levels of city in our scene here
and i'm wondering if we can get like a
nice like step system so like the big
one goes to the
medium one which goes to the small one i
think we need one more which is a small
one in between the medium and the small
one
and we'll hold ctrl
to duplicate and we'll give it just one
last one
at maybe like 30
or 50 because i think the original one
i tiberian
my goodness thank you sir thank you
thank you that is very generous
um wow yeah thanks for what you said a
few streams back it's
resulted in me applying to vfx
university course so thank
you to you and also to wren too dude
shout outs man that is awesome
that is freaking sweet man
um i'm glad that these help you out and
good luck to you
at your application for vfx university
have fun with it man learn as much as
you can
have a good time make those connections
it's going to be a good one
y'all are awesome you all are sick thank
you so much
all right so
here we go let's keep going all right um
now you can see that all this stuff is
kind of rendered uniformly it's placed
uniformly and we don't want that we want
it to be random so all you have to do is
go to your cloner
and where would it be clones
random so now it's randomly distributed
and if you come at it from a low angle
you can kind of get rid
of any tiling
or anything like that and it's also
going to be better because we're going
to turn the lights off on this thing
it's going to be sick all right so let's
try and make some like
some roads or something or should we
save that
for once we get the lights let's get the
lights popping off yo
like let's get some lights going we want
to get this look
right we want to get the lights that's
the biggest thing is the lights okay
um so how we can do that
how the heck are we going to do that
well first we save a new iteration
and let's see what we can do all right
let's hop into
let's turn off actually all these guys
or we can pull these three planes out so
we're just getting the one
we'll push these guys off to the side
and we want to distribute lights
randomly across this cityscape so
you can do this a bunch of different
ways but mainly the idea
is we're going to mess with the emission
tab alright the emission tab is going to
give us what we want
now with specular you do not have the
emission tab all right
so what you need to do is one of two
things
if you're an octane we will go instead
of glossy you can change it to a diffuse
which is totally fine you still get your
displacement you just don't get any
you know reflection which i think is
fine in this case or if you still want
the reflection you can change it to a
universal material
and just take down the metallic level
that way you keep the specular
and you get this emission box so let's
mess with that let's pull the submission
box out
let's set it to a texture emission
which is going to emit something like if
i were to pull an image from google it's
going to
use that image to light the scene or to
light the material or the shader
like a projector would light up a wall
or something like that
right all right so
we want to take the texture node and
give it an image texture
but what image are we going to use to
light this
you can do it with a bunch of different
ones
you can do with anything you want but we
want to get that look of city lights so
you got to be
a little specific about what you use
here i'm going to try something i've
never tried before
and we're going to see if this works so
i have a
surface imperfection pack that i created
there's also a video if you guys want to
learn how to make your own
it's on my channel but let's see if i
can find these textures
surface imperfections cool
i think we're good with the 2k version
and i have these ones
dust i have these dust ones you can see
here
that it kind of looks like stars maybe
it'll look like city lights i'm just
gonna give it a shot
and see what happens and
it currently it looks like
it's it needs to be scaled up or
something so let's take
the transform value and let's actually
give it a projection
we'll set the projection to box
and we'll set the transform to like two
what if we set it to 10
so we're kind of getting like a city
grid look going on here maybe we set it
to 20.
and then you can really see it tiling
and repeating which is no good
let's go back to 10 you still see the
tiling and repeating but we can get rid
of that in a second here
now what we'll do is it's time to take
away
the the hdri environment because
technically it'd be at night time
which you know technically it's not
black but let's just set it to black so
i'm going to hit this little gray button
that lets us choose a color and we'll
just turn it
to black
now i also want to take
these materials here i want to set the
diffuse value to black
as well i don't want it coloring i don't
want these buildings to be any other
color than black
we'll do the same for these you can
select all of them and do
batch adjustments you should be able to
where were you at
why is that not working
oh it's because they're not universal
materials probably
i don't know it's weird i'll set it to
universal
bring this down we'll do this to these
three here
aaron yo dude thank you for the super
chat
much appreciated brother um i'm glad you
joined me live
i am very glad you joined me live these
are fun um he says thanks for the
inspiration
and the constant enthusiasm all the time
keep it up see
cc4 life cc
cinema 4d that's awesome dude thank you
so much that's very
very generous of you um i'm glad you're
learning
and i'm glad you're having a good time
um dean will you be able to get the
project file not now but maybe soon
maybe soon it's a little foreshadowing
for y'all
good times good times okay last one
let's change it to universal and we'll
take the metallic down okay
um now maybe we can change yeah so now
they're all the same we can change these
all to black
cool we don't want any specular either
just darkness dude like my soul
just dark perfect okay so it's
it's lit it's lit
in a way that makes it seem
whoa
what's going on
all right here we go we'll save out
zoom in
all right so it's peppered so intensely
it looks like it's gray
so what we need to do is go to this
image texture here
and set the gamma to like five
and then you start to see
a little city grid coming to life here
it's starting to make sense it's all
starting to make
sense okay
so you can see the tiling most
definitely you can see the tiling okay
so okay um sodon what the heck is
gamma good question so gamma if i'm in
after
effects gamma is basically
um this middle slider
and it allows you
to kind of crank it up or down
and when you lower your gamma it makes
it a bit more washed out and brighter
when you raise your gamma it crunches it
down and makes it darker and more
contrasty
so that's basically all you need to know
when it comes to this so when i raised
my gamma
to say five it made it a bit more
contrasty if i set it to one
it doesn't look like it doesn't look
like it's too washed out it's using too
much of the image to light
ours our city you can set it to six
and have a good time with that that's
that's awesome you can also take your
texture emission
and check surface brightness which will
i don't technically know what that does
but it makes it brighter it's like more
accurate or something
and you can also take the power up to
like 200
to get more of a look we're gonna take
care of this tiling here in a second
um but another thing i want to do
is actually color this light
and the best way to do that would be
throw an octane gradient in between the
image texture
and the emission node and instead of
white our image is a black and white
image black and white
instead of white maybe it's more of like
a
tungsten oh let me get that city
we get that nice city awesome awesome
now you can also butter chuckles i love
you too
thank you thank you very much you can
also take that gradient
and throw another color in here maybe
it's
a oh where am i
what is this whoo
gear let me close that okay let's try it
again
there we go all right too many options
y'all there's a lot of options here
um those yellow lights look like moscow
let's reference our image what does our
image look like so we have a mixture of
white lights tungsten lights some blue
lights
let's get that out of here get get get
get get get
i hate this thing dude i hate these
freaking notifications
so we have a mixture of lights and
actually the fog value
like the smog value colors it orange
like you're talking that moscow look
into the back here
right so maybe we we mess with some fog
in a second you know
maybe we do that okay but i agree i
agree it's a little too intense right
now so let's
let's go for a white light and then we
also have a tungsten light
in here just a little bit
just a little bit and we can actually
set this to stepping so the size or
the interpolation you set to step
oop but we need there we go
you can have more of the image be like
the tungsten
how does this work yeah so you're kind
of crunching
see maybe we flip these
so the brightest lights are like white
and then it kind of comes down to
maybe we don't step this one maybe this
one's smooth
or they all kind of have to be smooth
okay
the step worked i liked it or maybe
blend with bland
let's go for step
cool all right so you kind of get a mix
here
you should be at least
maybe we can solo this
see what it looks like that doesn't help
too much but anyway you can mess with
your colors here
to get different values it's like we
have to tweak this and mess with it we
can come back here
but the way i like working um is
basically
working from as as general as possible
down to specifics
so you don't want to waste your time
working on tiny little specific details
right out the gates you want to work it
in generally so you get the general vibe
of your scene
you lay your giant brush strokes you do
your sketch and then you go in for
detail so that's the way
um you know that's the way i work
with anything with anything if i'm
modeling texturing
um writing even you start with outline
you know
it all it all works so yeah let's let's
hop back
in here
all right so
let's keep moving let's keep doing this
thing all right
um it's seamless we want to make it
seamless
so what i'm going to do
is we can do a number of things actually
we can
mix these two together and rotate it
randomly and see let's see what happens
um i could also use a different image i
can also use a noise map
to do it so maybe
how about this we'll do both we'll do
all three we have this image texture
okay let's
copy it ctrl drag and let's change it
out for a new one
maybe it's gonna be this fiber one
um yeah why not let's try this fiber one
so this is like little speckles of dust
and stuff
let's drag this into yep and see what
that looks like so
it's crunched a little too much let's
just try setting it to like four
or even 2.2 but it comes in by default
and let's take the transform
down to two and then we'll crank the
gamma back up so that
you're only getting a little bit of
those lights and there's still
too many of them so
we can so this is like this is basically
our color gradient let's make a new
gradient
an octane gradient and let's just bring
the black value up
that way we're only getting a little bit
of these lights just
we're trying to crunch it down we can
take the transform and go back to like
four
so we get a bit more of that detail
there
maybe we don't crunch it down as much
maybe these lights are a little
a little dimmer so we can take this
white value down to like a gray
and it dims dims them up a little bit
and what we can do from here we can
actually rotate this
let's just i don't know this will do
much for us but we can rotate it
to give us a different look and then
we'll mix these together okay so
we want to mix this guy and this guy
okay with a mix node we'll plug texture
one
in there texture two so we're mixing
these together and let's put that in the
gradient
now right now it's doing a perfect 50 50
blend by default the amount
is set to a perfect 50 50. if i go
to one side it gets this one image if i
go to the other side it gets us the
other image but
we don't want to do that we actually
like i said we're going to do all three
methods
meaning it's time to use a noise uh a
noise node in octane
so for the amount we're going to plug in
a noise
node octane noise and the projection i
always set to
x y z to u v w which gets you a seamless
you know a seamless uh
integration of the noise map there and
then for transform
let's pop one out i'm sure we'll need it
so right click and solo it to see what's
going on all right
so it's very small and
very um washed out so the first thing i
do
when messing with noise regardless of
whether it's going to be this contrasty
is set it to 100. that way you can see
what's going on
from here we want to scale it up let's
just scale it up to 15.
um okay so it's getting
us this
this pattern here because technically
hmm what's the best ah okay because
we're gonna come in and we're going to
duplicate this material across a bunch
of different planes all right so i
wouldn't worry about this tiling
quite yet because we can scale up
different city pieces
with a random modifier but we'll get
there okay
so from here we're going to use this
noise map to break up
the random look of all this stuff mobius
studios
i see you thank you for the super chat
appreciate you my friend
um so yeah we're gonna we're gonna use
this to break up all of these uh
all of these lights in two seconds time
for a little drink break
all right so
all right here we go so basically
we're going to use this to break up
those lights all right
let's go ahead and set the octaves to 8
and the omega
it's a 0.8 and you can see it makes it a
little bit rockier
gives a bit more detail in there let's
disable that
and you can see it's kind of breaking it
up in that way without
it if i didn't have it it'd be this
we'll compare
we'll store the render buffer we'll plug
this in
and we'll reveal you can see it's kind
of doing something but i don't like how
it still feels uniform
and i'm trying to figure out a way
i wonder if i
let me just try this let me delete
these other materials let me plug these
planes back
into the the cloner
i'll make four duplicates
i'll plug each one of these in
right now it's going to look the same
and then i'll start changing things with
each one of these so
with this material
let's go ahead and go to the
displacement
and let's set that to 120
so you can see that's breaking up
the pattern there because it raised
those guys in the back if i set it to
150
or even just 2 000
you can see that it's doing something to
a number of these all right so let's
let's take that back down let's just go
to like 150 i think is fine for what
we're doing
and we can take that guy and we can
leave it bright because those buildings
are going to be shining bright
next let's do let's see okay so that's
our
normal one the second one here is our
big buildings
the third one let's go ahead and apply
the third one
and let's see the displacement we'll set
it to 80.
so we'll kind of raise some other guys
off the ground just a little bit
and then we'll do the last one
we'll set it to like 20 or something
let's see last one we'll just set to
we'll set the 15 maybe so let's kind of
get leveled out a little bit
now you can change the brightness of all
this because it looks like a
just a generic wash this has shape to it
you know you can see the roads you can
see how the
the lights are broken up by the
mountains there's not
many um lights up in the mountains here
so we want to do that as well and we
want to get these roads going
so let's work on that all right let's
see if we can't get that
first thing i'm gonna try is actually
taking
well well let's let's give this a shot
let's let's take this let's open it up
into like a grid system here so there's
a little bit
of road shining through
right you can see like the underside
this dark area
and let's let's take
let's take a plane we'll scale it up
we will lower it we can set the width
and height segments to one
we can lower it like minus two
centimeters so it's underneath all this
let's make a new material apply that
to that plane
and let's go into that material let's go
ahead and
hide our cloner for a second
we should if we refresh our octane view
yeah there we go that is actually pretty
sweet
that's cool let's save another iteration
and if you guys are just joining i'm
using a um an image texture from one of
my surface
displacement packs um to
light a plane here um and give it some
shape
using a displacement map we created in
after effects right here so it's pushing
these white pixels up
and pushing these black pixels down to
give us this kind of city look here
which is sick i love it um
but let's make it brighter so let's go
ahead and bring our cloner back in
and it doesn't look like anything right
now because it's all the same value but
if we
maybe let's see let's take the texture
mission let's set it to like 500.
okay why is that not working maybe we
set it to a thousand
turn off our cloner
and maybe we
instead of black
maybe it's just a light gray that way it
actually has a little bit of room to be
illuminated with
and then we can take
these image textures that are lighting
our scene
and we can bring down the amount
that's being crunched by
okay so that's way too much
let's take the noise and set this to
like
50. contrast maybe it's 20
and the gamma goes down
maybe we mess with the transform of this
thing so it's a
smaller size
bring our cloners back in that's
definitely brighter
so now boom there you go now you have
some freaking cars going down here like
this gives the
the feeling of
of a city if you look closely obviously
it's not but it gives the
feeling of a city this is so sick
i love this um now let's take it to the
next level
so the city lights if we go in here
let's go to
maybe we adjust some of the colors here
so we can do let's hop into
any one of our original city materials
and let's go to the the gradient
let's switch these around so we have
some white lights popping off
you can see that maybe we go to another
one and we do the same
we hit it with some white lights
but maybe we want to just
maybe it's green maybe it's like a
tungsten
kind of a feel like that's
that's pretty sweet and then the cars
down here can be a mix of
tungsten and red because the brake
lights
right and else but it also has white
lights too so
maybe how are we going to do this
so let's go to our gradient let's set a
couple colors here so we have white
lights
and we have red brake lights
you can kind of see those popping off
throughout the city down there
it's pretty sweet
whoa that's cool
so you have a mix of these three colors
the red i'm trying to get the red like
to be
just the small part of it but it's such
a large part
maybe it's uh maybe my knots need to be
smooth
again
i'm glad y'all are enjoying those uh
those satisfying renders
it's a good time it's a very good time
and then let's try
hmm that's feeling pretty cool to me
that's feeling pretty nice
actually so if we're matching our
picture here our reference image that
ren took
we're not we're not doing too bad
actually we're not doing too bad at all
i think it looks pretty nice
that looks pretty nice so one thing i
need to work on is the horizon
which we'll get to as well as our camera
angle let's start to set up our camera
angle
all right so i
like the idea of the person center frame
kind of framed by the roads here i like
that a lot
so maybe we can try that maybe we can
try and get that look going i can see
some main roads coming down here it's a
bit too uniform but actually
maybe not maybe not
this is a cool look just cause i'm amped
about it let's throw in some fog real
quick
um i'm gonna hop out of the camera
oh this is gonna be sick this is gonna
be sick
all right let's let's go to the volume
uh
generate set the voxel size to 100 if
you set that any lower
guys y'all if you set that any lower
than five
your system will crash okay you do not
want to do it
because it's only for the viewport this
voxel size editor
it's only for the viewport all right
so when we move this you're gonna see
some like cards some planes here okay
and if you set that any lower you can
see how if i go 50
uh okay it's getting somewhere if i go
20 and the viewport is starting to chug
but if i go i don't want to do it i'm
not even going to do it so i set that to
100.
you'd think if the number's higher it's
going to be crazier but nah not in this
case
so we're going to cover our city with
our fog
or our smog i guess let's raise it off
the ground
pull it up let's get to a nice view
let's turn it off find our good view we
can set
our camera angle to like an 85.
we'll hop in
and maybe the 85 is like
maybe we needed that 35.
because i like the idea of just seeing
like two main roads
and we can always add detail into the
roads and like make it
a bit windier or something or not as
uniform but we'll get there
also aspect ratio what do we want um i
like the tall view i think tall view is
cool
but wide view is also cool too because
we have to make a new thumbnail for this
once we make the image
so for this though i think i'm gonna go
tall view
um i'm gonna do three by
four so that would be
i'm gonna go 1500 as my base so 1500
times three
or is it two by two 2x3 or 4x4
[Music]
oh boy all right let's get some water
water
oh man
[Music]
good times
good times indeed all right shall we
continue
shall we continue no i don't have the
rhona all right
just talk for hours on end
let's go back in let's do it
is that g fuel it's just water son
what up isaac thanks for joining
all right y'all this is a good one this
is a good stream
okay our fog
yes our fog let's bring it in
it's all nutty let's hide it in
the viewport all right there's this
first little stop sign so we get a green
light then you get a red light so that
you don't see it in viewport but we keep
it in the render view
oh i didn't do this um
with 600 by
900
and we lock it and that way
that way you can actually get the whole
deal so let's go 0.5
we can just walk it up until you see the
whole thing right there boom sweet
all right obviously way
way to
foggy alright so we want
to let's bring this down a little bit
let's go to the medium click this little
white box and we'll set the density to
one
and that is a scary city that is very
scary
the absorption and scattering are going
to be clutch here because it's an
orange looking fog alright we want to
crank the scattering phase
so it kind of scatters the light a bit
more but not
too much not too much
dude this reminds me of a picture though
yo i took this picture in shanghai
sorry quick aside i took this picture
in shanghai that this kind of reminds me
of
let me see if i can pull it up for you
guys
um so i have
a print store called noise green and
light
i love doing film photography
that's what this is here a lot of film
photography so this is this is in
shanghai this image here let me just go
to the collections page and we'll go to
shanghai
and it's dude it's this one on the right
this one on the right
um i tweaked the colors a little bit but
it reminds me of this right here like
this
is such a cool field you can see the
smog going off into the back
same deal this is all shanghai you can
see the fog and the smog going off into
the back on all of these
and that's what we're trying to get so
you always want to reference always
always a reference
right um so it's good to you know
pick your images here get your reference
and
you know have a good time but yeah if
you guys like photography and stuff
check it out i also got a little store
going
um i'm selling this one this is limited
edition
only 50 prints of each size
um and i got some other good ones in
here anyway that's not the point of this
video
i'm talking about the city so you can
see it's dark right if we're referencing
that red
that red light it's it's uh it's too
dark
so we can keep taking down the density
and maybe that will help us and
the scattering phase yeah we'll bring
that up a little bit
but we also want to adjust
and i mix this up all the time it's
either the absorption or the scattering
so if we set
one of these to like a brighter orange
it should get us yeah that kind of
gives you a bright orange going off into
the back there
but maybe it's this one maybe it's the
scattering
octane jesus david um david the man
himself
he's uh he's the bomb when it comes to
this stuff
he knows the difference he's got a nice
octane course on uh grayscale gorilla
so that's not bad they're kind of the
same color let me just try changing one
of those to like
freaking purple
okay so it takes the opposite color and
kind of tints these things that color so
this is where your
orange comes in your moscow orange
let's take the saturation down
so you kind of have that orangish
tint as it goes off into the background
and then what if we mess with this guy
if we just set this to white okay i
think the fog is still just too thick so
i think you need to go like point one on
that
and i want it to kind of get brighter
too
but that's not bad that's not bad at all
um
i actually kind of like that i think
maybe what we'll do is we'll just add
some more lights we'll add some really
bright city stuff
off here into the background and that'll
that'll combat that that'll be nice
so i'm digging that a lot let's make
sure we save
now it's i think we're at the point now
um in our render where we can actually
try and put a subject in the foreground
i like that look
um and i want to maybe add
like a power line or a flag waving
in the wind or something i want to mess
with that so i think we got a really
nice
look right now um with this
so let's let's keep going in and again
guys
remember this is all dude this is
all just like look how my frame rate
it's a 200 i'm flying through this thing
granted i do have a quadro popping off
but like
it's because we're using displacement
maps
and texture in emission to get this even
with the fog
it's moving so fast we only have like
what is this 10 but we only have 100
polygons in our scene let's let's let's
double check just to be sure i think
it's
alt v will bring you to this little
viewer here
you can go to hud and we can come down
and we can do
let's do total polygons
um total objects
selected polygons and total polygons
maybe it's not counting it because it's
in our cloner or something but we just
have nine objects in our scene
it's very small y'all it's very small
that's that's the way we're not blowing
up our computer
and we can mess with i think the color
correction settings
which i'm gonna do right now let's set
that to like 1.5
there you go you start to brighten it up
a little bit it's gonna take some time
to render and get that noise out but
i think it's looking really sweet um
let's check our octane settings
you wanna make sure your gi clamp is at
one it's usually set to like a million
like some dumb number um
and you get these fireflies that suck
you set that to one it gets rid of all
that stuff so i've actually
set a default scene by setting up my
camera
and everything and going to window
customization
save as default scene so every time i
open it up all my settings already done
and it's no problem
so one thing we could do dude we could
add a city back here we can add some
really big buildings in the back
which i might do um why not because
we're here and it's looking cool all
right so
let's get that foreground guy how we
gonna do it
how are we going to do it
so you could probably go
hmm you could probably go to
i think there's a website
let's see
i think it's like 3d people or something
3d
people and it's photo scans of 3d
renderpeople.com yep this is the one you
you've probably
seen these around
i'm hesitant to
i'm hesitant to grab something maybe
maybe i
maybe i should i don't know
let's try this one heck why not
cinema 4d
let's do it let's save it in the right
place
save this and we'll navigate
and extract
and we will boom
octane i already got it for octane
renderpeople.com
sweet that's awesome
all right let's get out of here
several plugins are missing okay
let it load for a second
that's perfect
that's perfect
so we're looking for silhouette that's
it you know like we can bring
[Music]
this woman in let's go ahead and copy
her and
bring her into our night city scene
we'll go ahead and paste
now my scale is way off but that's
okay we're going to rotate her
90 degrees bring her
up and back and it's
obviously too intense now
let's hop out of the camera
and we're going to cheat it now
obviously
this shot here it's it's on an iphone
and it's zoomed in
um i'm standing on a mountain and ren is
looking
down into the city okay
so if we want to go for that same look
this is
technically looking down into the city
but i think the character itself
needs to be
control this is the control i guess cool
kind of facing down there
and the pose isn't right definitely need
to you know mess with the pose
um ghoulius boozler what a ridiculous
name thank you for the super chat
uh i appreciate you very much thank you
thank you
thanks for always sharing your knowledge
with the community absolutely
yeah absolutely i'm glad you guys are
learning something um the more you learn
the better and we do this every single
week every saturday at 10 45
a.m pacific standard time so keep
hopping in we're doing it all year it's
gonna be a good one we're gonna learn a
lot
all right back to it
so let's see let's see if we can't
what i like about this image is that
like
the darkness kind of creeps up to the
bottom of the frame i like that a lot
so maybe
maybe what we can do i mean like that's
definitely a gradient
you can do that with a gradient in
photoshop
certainly so
i wonder how maybe we push our volume
out
in a way okay that cleared it too far
i like it where it is
sweet okay
go ahead and save another iteration now
we're at the fun stuff now like we've
done most of the hard work
so let's see if we can't get her
in a pose we like
and maybe maybe this you know she's not
the best person
for this
we don't know yet you know we still have
to mess with it once we get her in place
we can
can we scale her down or does that mess
with the yeah that messes with
maybe i can scale her down this way 0.5
there we go
now she's kind of smaller in frame which
i like
and we'll give it um let's make a new
terrain a new landscape in c4d
we'll bring this up
and again my my like my scene
positioning is way off
but it's okay you know we're kind of
just going for what looks good in camera
technically you'd want to do this to
scale
but i'm not too worried let's make a new
[Music]
material
drop it on the mountain turn it black
scale it up maybe bring this down
so you got a nice like rocky kind of
look here we'll bring this down let's
make sure she's actually
on the mountain
something like that
maybe we can give some more detail so
like 300 by 300
in the mountain gives it a bit more
detail and this is where most of our
polygons are coming from it's crazy
but i'm not liking i think it needs some
bloom so maybe let's go into the camera
imager
and we'll go to post processing and
we'll take down the glare
amount we'll set it to one glare angle
doesn't really matter because i think
we're going to take the glare off but
you see how it's blooming into
the foreground there and it gets you a
nice
kind of a nice look take the volume
bring it back to center oh
i think .05 is a little much we'll go
point one on it
the landscape and bring it down
and this is just all shaping your scene
we're just here to shape our scene
yes i know she's floating but not too
concerned with that
um we want to get an interesting
silhouette here i'm not too interested
with the silhouette i don't like it that
much so you could do any number of
things to
you know switch this out you can use
mixamo
um you know and
find any number of poses or animations
that you like
the character silhouette matters
so you can choose characters on miximo
as well let me let me just show you guys
because i'm probably gonna end up doing
this i don't know if i'm gonna do it on
the stream
let's go to mixamo.com
and i'm gonna log in over here
real quick so you guys can see
see what's going on miximo is great
all right i think we're in
alright so you can go to characters and
grab any
character you want to be standing on top
of this mountain
in miximo you guys recognize this one
maybe maybe not
you can get headphones maybe some
headphones going i think that could be
kind of cool actually
i like that and then we can do
back to animations and just type in idle
and like you know just any one of these
is standing
looking down you know moving around i
mean there might be one
sitting that could be cool
kicking back on the mountain top maybe
you know you could go through and
you know crisscross applesauce up on the
mountain you guys get the idea
but for now i'm just gonna i'm gonna
work with this
okay so
let's try adding a big city in the
background because that's gonna look
pretty sweet i think
um let's check yeah that's such a cool
i like that pose a lot it's a really
cool pose
i dig it
all right let's see if we can't get that
city in the back so what we can do is
literally just make a new plane
um it doesn't even have to be in the
cloner
we can control drag it out of the cloner
and let's hop back into our scene
let's grab that plane bring it to the
center
and this one will make a new material
for it ctrl drag
and let's set the texture
emission no the displacement will set to
like 300
and then we'll drop it on to that new
plane
there and we get some bigger buildings
you can see here you got some larger
buildings
doing a thing and you can also take the
emission
let's see
so i'm taking the gamma down on
these image textures see so it's more of
a city kind of a look here
maybe we set that to
we scale that down to five or something
and maybe we go
four on the gamma and that gets us more
of a city kind of building look
three maybe i don't know eight or
something like that could look pretty
sweet
that's not bad at all and then we can
also continue to take this displacement
and crank it so we can go 400
so they're taller or you can go
a thousand so they're really tall but
let's go back into camera and see what
it looks
like
pretty sweet pretty freaking sweet
you can also take those guys and
change the color just a little bit maybe
make it
uh more of a white light
i don't know the orange is nice
maybe we set it to more of a whiter
orange or something
and we can take that plane and we can
scale it up
put it in the middle of our scene and we
got a big old city you can push it back
and you can take the brightness up like
crazy
on the emission so like 200 to 400
maybe it's a thousand so it's really
bright back there
you can also duplicate that ctrl drag to
duplicate
r to rotate scale it down
and you have like a little city
structure that you're piecing together
now
whoa
to give it layers right so you have a
city off in the background there
you can push just push that down
underground
and you can get a cool look like that
like that's fun dude that's
that's actually pretty sweet i am i am
digging that
you can take the other two guys and you
know and have them
lower down as well because you really
want the main one
to to be the tallest
right
like that's that's pretty sweet i don't
think we need the
fourth one
yeah if you guys ever seen um ian
hubert's
lazy tutorials this is kind of
reminiscent of that just a little bit
same kind of idea um
and yeah i did make the displacement
texture myself i just did it in after
effects you know
mosaic with some fractal noise that i
didn't even touch i didn't even change
this you can make a bunch of different
ones to give
give you like different looks in the
city so
maybe um maybe we take this
fractal noise element we had we changed
the evolution maybe we changed it to
swirly instead
[Music]
you know any one of these subscale
small bumps we could try this and we can
transform it up
so we can scale this up like this and
then throw the mosaic on and you still
you get a different mosaic
look let's try it let's save this out
um control m will get you to the render
queue
um we'll do a jpeg sequence
and we'll just call this i don't know
comp 2 because we already have comp one
bam saved out and then you can
you know grab any one of these
materials that are on your pl your your
planes here and your cloner that's
making up your city
you can grab any one of those hop in
and replace this texture
here two boom no
and you're gonna get a different a
different look we can change
the gamma to i don't know maybe
five or something we can take the
displacement
from 15 to 45
or maybe even 100
and you can see that you're getting
these little
you know buildings here if i go to
full scale maybe we go double
you're getting these buildings popping
up here
just like that and that's because it's
more it's more of a higher contrast so
the whites are popping off
you know versus the other one which was
a bit more subdued
i think it was just basic you can see
how it's more subdued
so you're getting more more buildings
more general buildings lifted off the
ground
but here you're getting kind of some
sparse
buildings popping up we can also take
that one take the texture emission and
crank it to 400 too
that way we get it's brighter in the
bigger buildings
um and we can take perhaps we can take
this down to like six
and four so these buildings get a little
bit
brighter which is a really cool look
and it's up to you you know if you want
to keep that
but that's not bad i like it i think
it's cool
it gives a really cool vibe
all right
so you know at at this point
we have a pretty cool look we got the
silhouette we got the city with the
streets
um different colors i could probably
tweak the colors in the city
a little bit more we got a big buildings
you know big
a big city in the background and it just
gives you that feeling
you know a really cool feeling so i
think maybe the next thing i want to do
is see about adding
a bit more foreground detail um
that kind of like goes off into the
background
and and perhaps maybe adding like a flag
or something or some pipes
going off down into the city to draw the
eye a bit more
we'll see yeah let's let's see what we
can do there
because i think we've had you guys get
the point you use this placement maps
and you use
different textures or noise to make the
city lights pop
off so i think that's that's a really
cool look
all right so
let me pull up my references
you know there's this video here
which has you know brighter strips
um angled streets
there's the flag idea um
and yes i do read comments i do read
comments of course of course i read
comments
and there's your silhouette you know
there's a cool silhouette going so it
really is like
trying to find an interesting silhouette
for the foreground
um that reads and like this is cool i
like
it's a bunch of people you're telling a
story with the silhouette versus the
generic silhouette that we have right
now which i don't like
um
you also see the sky too in the
background which is cool
and there's your you know there's your
telephone pole situation
so maybe maybe we can
[Music]
maybe we can drop in a little sky
element back there
and maybe there maybe we have some flags
or something in the foreground this is
this is really when you just get the
spice on it
um which could take hours and hours who
knows
who knows also here's another thing that
you can do to mix up the scene go to
your cloner
um and let's go with a random effector
and you get a random look isn't that
sweet let's turn off position
let's go to rotation and just
rotate these guys randomly
and rotate them this way too like that
looks pretty crazy
that's pretty sweet huh
that could be cool you know lots of
different lots of different techniques
you can do with this
um position you can have city
floating in the air let's turn these
down
that's pretty nuts
it's just a way to break it up yep just
a bunch of different ways you can do
to break this up that's fun
very very fun um yeah we just tweak and
tweak and tweak until we get something
we like
i'm wondering if
we can get a sky back there
let me try it let me just make an octane
sun
and see what we can do let's rotate this
around
so the sun's pointing right at us
and then we'll drop it below the horizon
and i don't know i don't know if it
gives us too much let me turn off the
fog
i want that like blue
let's see in the reference so in the
reference here you guys saw
it was like the the red orange to blue
kind of a look to to black
so i want to try and get that that's
just orange right now you can change the
sky
color let me see if i can't change the
daylight model
maybe a different daylight model will
get us
a different look here let me let me zero
this stuff
out
just to be sure okay cool
whoa
okay so sky color and
sun color
maybe we can mix these if sky color is
like
an intense blue well that turns green
what on earth
sun color maybe
so it's like you're trying to trying to
go for a
a gradient
i'm gonna try something crazy i'm gonna
try something crazy let me
hop out of here i'm going to make a
plane
and let's set it to 90 degrees i'm
holding shift to snap
the angle there let's open this up stand
it
up just tall enough yep just tall enough
there let's bring it just so the edges
are right in our view there so we can
have full control over this
boom all right so from here
i'm gonna try something crazy let's see
if this works
i'll bring this in
and you can see it alright it's already
kind of working it's being it's being
lit
by our scene here
scoot this over and have it face
our camera directly open it up just a
little bit more
okay we'll save let's save a new
iteration
and let's see if we can't get that
gradient across this
sky um we'll do a diffuse material we'll
drop it on the plane back there we'll
hop
in let's go to node view because you
want to see what you're doing
and the diffuse
image tech no not an image texture we
want a
octane gradient
and we want to go from
let's see what's the easiest way to see
this let's turn on some
lights
let me just grab an hdri
cool that's fine i'll hop out of the
camera we can hide the cloner
and this plane here and let's just see
if we can't get these colors correct
all right um
mike yo thank you thank you for the
super chat i appreciate you
um he says love the recent satisfying
render i'm very glad
and i hope you were satisfied it was
really satisfying to make
um and you know the other guys sam ren
and peter put out some really solid
stuff too
but man thanks for joining me thanks for
hanging out live it's a good time
i hope you're learning a lot um and yo
if you guys aren't part of the discord
community definitely
join up because we do weekly challenges
and pretty soon here i'm going to
announce the five winners of
last week's weekly challenge which was
dream and i'm going to announce the new
weekly challenge
this week um sometimes there's there's
prizes
i think there might be a prize today it
might be my surface imperfection pack
um there might be a prize uh next week
too
i don't know sometimes it's sometimes
sometimes
but yeah um i appreciate you all let's
wrap this up let's see if we can get the
sky going
maybe a little bit more foreground and
then we'll we'll announce the winners
of the live stream or no no the weekly
challenge
my brain starts to get lost here um
[Music]
after so much talking but let's hop back
in
let's hop back in
okay um pella i am glad
that you think i'm really good at
streaming because
uh i don't think so and
i'm trying to get better i've learned a
lot over the last
couple mornings and i hope that you know
some
small subtle stuff like the scene
switching is cool and i got actually a
really exciting
art review scene for y'all when we get
to that point so
let's keep moving let's keep
moving all right let's get this um let's
get these these colors in the sky here
we want these colors popping off
the orange and it goes up to a light
blue into a dark blue into a black
we want to get that look okay so i'm
wondering if we can actually reference
this here let's find out so let's bring
up
our node editor we have a gradient and
we want to
choose some colors along this gradient
that's going to match our sky
now it looks like the gradient is being
applied
from i can't
quite tell
uh
like if this goes from yellow
to blue
it's like the middle note
how do i get it
so that it's going from yellow to blue
up top
click linear
constant cubic
why does it not work
i want the whole thing uvs maybe
no it should it should just work
um setting above radial
linear
well what the heck happened
ah there we go so you hit you hit linear
versus radial
whoa that's crazy um thank you
who said that miron thanks dude
appreciate it good times all right so
maybe that's how we need to do the
lights
maybe um okay so let's see if we can't
reference these colors
in this video can we pick
these colors we can
yes boom
and i'm just gonna work my way up
all right
so that's kind of it um we need to flip
it upside down
and that's kind of the vibe
maybe we need to open up the brighter
part a little bit
like that
that's pretty cool yeah
yeah that's cool i dig that i think that
works
it kind of gives us the look going here
oh snap yo
here kirillotron
dude heck yeah thanks for the super chat
that's awesome dude um
so you said about the color of the sky i
think you should try the last sky
model as the most realistic and check
the scale of the scene in 3ds max for
example this is usually the
cause of many problems all right the
last sky model let's give it a shot
let's
bring up that sky so see that's what
yeah those are the colors i want
the scale of the scene so maybe
sun size
is that it 0.2
that's certainly it it's like scaled up
over
let's see let's see i think yeah we're
on to something here
maybe i should need to rotate this whole
thing that's not
it how do i rotate the horizon
hmm oh
i was too focused y'all
um ion and thank you
uh you're enjoying the streams thanks
for the super chat you've been watching
corridor crew for the last three years
took up rendering earn your first
paycheck did it last did it last month
dude congratulations that is awesome
keep up the good work dude keep learning
keep growing
keep growing your value hopefully the
paychecks will get bigger
um and just keep working on the stuff
that you're passionate about that's how
you
keep that spark going so thank you guys
for the support
um and ion it's a cool name
appreciate you man all right
so i need to figure out how to rotate
the horizon it looks like i mean
i could just tilt my camera up
i guess
and get the look but i kind of i need it
like in its most
crunched form you know
maybe we bring the volume back in
and i don't want the sun i don't want
any sun power i just want the sky
the sun determines what the sky is i
don't know
power
bring the cloner back bring
the ground back
that looks pretty cool i think the fog
is a little thick
0.025 0.035
and how does that compare because we
want it to be dark
so let's get rid of
this octane sky we just want to set it
to black
and can we bring our
our sky in
let's see
sky color sun color let's see mix the
sky texture
no it doesn't really work we're just
playing around here
maybe bring the plane back in that has
our colors on it
and instead of just the diffuse
maybe it is an emissive
texture as well
because you can't see it obviously it
needs to actually have some light
pumping into it so let's take the
gradient
that we have here and let's push it to
the emissive
uh black body texture so that goes right
into
there and then you get a little bit of
it yeah you certainly get a little bit
of that
i think we need to adjust the gradient
that's not bad
that's not bad at all
now i'm wondering if you can blend does
that do it
a little bit better
and then maybe we brighten it up check
the surface bro oh god
set that to 10 yo son set that to
freaking
two not even like one
okay service brightness maybe a little
too intense maybe
maybe we just do it the old the old
normal way here 150 is not bad 100 i
mean 100
not bad either you got the glow from the
city
popping off the volume's doing a thing
that's not bad that's not bad at
all
sweet yeah and the fog kind of brings it
all
together
so let me just adjust some camera
settings real quick
and see what looks good
way too intense way too crunched
i mean portrait i always i always like
going to the portrait
look here um at 1.5
that looks cool neutral response we'll
check that because it gives you kind of
a green tint
the neutral neutral response button will
take out the color
from like the lut basically that you've
applied
but that's not bad dude that's not bad
um
let's see if our
volume is working
maybe i'll make that a little deeper
and we'll get that to scale up
and maybe we'll add a little bit more
fog
0.065
0.05 just so you see a little bit of
that light i wonder if you could just go
to like
0.065 and then we take
the sky back there and we
push the light up what that would look
like
and it's trying to push through the fog
maybe this is when we use
the surface power surface brightness
just want to keep it subtle
just get like a little bit of that sky
coming in i think that's good
that's nice cool and then
let's try moving this cloner
up
and making another plane
that has more of a darker
a darker bit of you know of texture to
it here
so i'll duplicate one of those
one of those guys we'll drop it on here
one of these materials
and do we raise it up a little bit
oh no that's not what we want that's
just pure black
we want one of these guys
on our plane where are you there you are
so what we're going to get is kind of a
great like a like a gradual
roll off um to darkness
versus that hard line so you can take
the power down to like
50.
and we'll take the height to like 20.
then you bring it up just like that
yeah that's not bad also another tip you
can uh
you can go to options and uncheck the
check camera option
and when you hop out of the camera your
live viewer will stay
and you can actually just you know keep
adjusting and whatnot
and i'm angling this to get a bit more
like detail here
in these lower bits
and we can brighten it up just maybe a
little more because it does go like to a
pretty harsh
kind of black there so
[Music]
if we go like 75
on the emission
that's not bad and i think the color
should be more uh
tungsten because these are homes the
lights are on
and we can create one more plane
inside of the cloner
and make it we'll duplicate it
and we'll set it to like a blue glow
instead
sweet
and i don't like
how it's being a randomly
cloned here
so i'm going to adjust the
the seed
and maybe i'll i'm gonna go back
on that blue i don't think it's that
great so let me just
undo it
boom
all right guys that's um
that's pretty close
we're just about there
it's feeling pretty good to me
um now we could do some foreground stuff
with some flags
i'm just wondering like how that would
look and feel in our scene
what do you guys think um is there
anything quick that we can do in the
foreground that you
think would be awesome i'm looking at
you all right now
what can we do in the foreground to
spice this up that would be reasonably
quick
maybe something that would add some
atmosphere what do you guys think
so grass i think grass would be not
necessary just because
it's just like adding noise on noise
especially since it's going to be such
like thin little silhouettes
it might help break up that line at the
bottom there
but i'm wondering if we can do it in
different ways um
[Music]
a street light a street light could be
interesting
maybe gargoyles are cool
a bench she's sitting on maybe yeah
certainly
a fence maybe a fence could be
interesting it just might not be like
it's got a lot of holes in it so i don't
know if that would read
immediately
a wind turbine that's kind of cool
that's pretty sweet an antenna
railing
maybe we go for like a electrical wire
kind of situation let me let me see what
we can do
with that i actually have
some stuff some assets vfx materials 3d
models cg
trader we got antennas
part one and part two like this one
something like this
maybe something like this
maybe um we need like
wires
um cranes electric towers
this is it right here electric towers
maybe we can get like some of this or
something
going in the scene down into the city
i don't know let's try it
let's give it a shot
all right so i'm gonna
check the camera here make sure it's
unchecked yep so when i hop out
i need to scale this down a lot
and we'll rotate it to face us
and we need to get to the point where
like you can see it like it's certainly
right there
right in the foreground which is kind of
cool
like that's actually pretty sweet
and it's getting like a nice underglow
from the city below
kind of cool maybe we scale it down a
little bit more bring it closer
yeah wires between two of them
i think is a is a given
you know like if we kind of lame if we
didn't do that you know
let me scale this down just a little bit
and maybe we control drag and get a
little symmetry going here
and we just kind of have them going off
into the night
and it just kind of ends
out in the distance and then we have one
of them
up here maybe behind
and it's very subtle but i think once it
like
clears up once the render clears up
you'll be able to see it a little bit
more
and let's see if we can get some wires
going between these guys
the best way to do that would probably
be
with toppo wire would probably be the
quickest way to do this
i think let me clean up my viewport so
it's easier to see you can hit
enqueue to get rid of textures and
n a to get rid of
any lines i also like to hide my camera
just in this case it's not really that
in the way
let's see what we can do here
so top of wire really cool plug-in
does it work with nulls like can i let
me save this let me make a new scene
just to clean things up top of wire and
i'll make a null
and another null and i'll move one over
here
and so you can see them i will
make it a freaking star why not
we got two of them and then i'll drop
both of them in the top of wire
and i guess not with cubes
it should work
we have one cube and two cubes and then
we adjust the top of wire
so distance limit maybe oh no
type
curvature we want oh why does it do that
i wonder why it's disappearing does
anyone have an idea why it's
disappearing
and then you want to give them thickness
obviously too distribution
vertex um
now the curvature is really what we need
to make this work
yeah this is a topo wire i'm trying to
figure out how to get this
thing to again
get some droopiness to it is it the
distance limit
the maximum let's just set that to 999
so it's maxed out
ah weird the curvature is not working i
think it's actually
broken in r23 last i heard
hmm
[Music]
yeah i don't know so maybe we don't use
top of wire and we do it the other way
so maybe we take
a spline and we go from one point
to another and we
select both of those points and we
subdivide
i think it's u and
p oh no that's split we want to
subdivide it
what's the what's the hotkey for
subdivide
i knew it what
us us
so i'm just hit this a bunch so we got
this thing subdivided
and we'll give it a
a where is it simulation tag
should we spline dynamics or cloth
i swear there's like a spline dynamics
or something
spline wrap edge to spline spline
dynamics there it is there's it's in a
hair tag
okay so we go hair tags
spline dynamics great so now you go to
it's been a minute since i've done this
so you select the end points
get some of those get some of those
and you should be able to set them hit
play
and it doesn't work
set is the other set button all right
there you go there you go okay
that's how you do it so you set it
and then you droop it and it's a good
time and you just gotta mess
with the stiffness maybe it's a hundred
percent
zero percent rubber so it falls and it
holds its weight just a little bit
more um and then finally
you can hit it with a circle spline
close that down and we'll go
to frame one select both of them hold
ctrl
and alt that way they're both they will
both become
children of the sweep and
you know make it a little smaller and
boom there you go
it's doing some weird stepping that i
don't like
so maybe that could be fixed with the
spline by setting it to
uniform natural adaptive
bezier linear i'm changing the trying to
change the spline
type to fix that stepping
but maybe it's in the sweep options or
possibly it could be in a lot of
different options here you probably
won't see it though
in our in our instance um
wow that's like really a really dense
mesh there
oh snap weekend subscribers right now
shoot son
that's awesome thank you guys thank you
um i have to figure out is that too
loud the subscriber thing i'm doing
i'm figuring that one out um
maybe i should just turn down the volume
on it
kinda yeah turn it down a little bit
tiny bit loud cool thank you guys
appreciate it
sweet heck yeah all right
so it looks like intestines but i don't
know why
i do not know why
dang the subscriptions coming in that's
what's up
all right so let's see
here what to do
is it my freaking spline dude why is it
all zig zaggy
maybe it's just the fact that like
huh
surrender it's your dad's birthday
and you left the chat not that's not
chill dude
it's not chill
i'm just kidding of course dude your
dad's awesome uh your dad is
literally the adult version of you uh
which is freaking awesome he
rides a one wheel how cool is that how
freaking cool is that
all right let's get some splines going
in our scene we want to get these
electric towers
roped up okay
so we'll do
spline pen tool we'll get like
let's see if we can do this quickly
quickly
and easily we'll go
one two
three and this is just where they stop
you know this is where the power ends
perfect all right let's go to top view
and make sure it lines
up give it a top of wire
no that actually that's actually perfect
let's take that we'll
ctrl a to grab all those points
and we're gonna subdivide so us
a whole bunch oh that's why
look it's got the bezier handles that's
why
i think you need to set it to linear
type linear i think that's it i think
that's our answer we'll see though
let's keep going us us
to subdivide we'll give that a shot
maybe we'll subdivide it one more time
but we'll we'll see
um
let's lock it up all right so right
click and we'll go to hair tags
spline dynamics let's select the points
the heck
what why'd it go down there
give it a spline dynamics tag and it
goes all crazy oh because we need to be
on frame one
probably
hair tag spline dynamics yeah stayed put
all right we'll go to point mode let's
just select these points on the ink
these anchor points here
and we'll see what happens
zoom holding shift to select multiple
points
awesome we'll select the spline dynamics
tag we'll set it
and moment of truth boom we got some
freakin splines
awesome awesome awesome okay let's see
if the stepping thing works
uh let's make go back to frame one
frame zero rather we'll make that circle
spline
we'll scale it down we'll select both
the spline in the circle spline hold
ctrl and alt and
drop it into a sweep scale down that
circle
and hit play and look at that the linear
um like the linear
what would you call it interpolation
fixed our problem it's not doing a weird
stepping thing because uh it doesn't
have bezier handles doing
a bunch of craziness but those let's
just see what that looks like
and let's see well actually
it is doing something you do see those
wires that's cool
um maybe we need to bring them more
towards the center
um would be the best way of doing this
i think we can actually pull this point
while it's live
yeah that's freaking cool
you pull that point while it's live and
it'll actually make some cool
adjustments
but we got this weird glitch here
we kind of want to just bring it more
towards the center behind our character
let's move it let's set our our frame
length
or our scene length to like a thousand
so we can have room to play with this
let's just move it so it's like
right behind our character
and we'll see what that looks like in
our scene
shoot samu
mr samu samu gindert
thank you thank you for the very
generous
super chat that is awesome very very
kind of you
so okay pronounced shamu
pronounced like shamu the killer will
awesome you just found out about my
channel yesterday after watching quarter
crew for
for a few years i gotta go now thanks
for awesome uh information and content
say how to run for me dude you rock
shamu thank you so much for the support
it means a lot
you are awesome have a good day i hope
you learned a lot and
yeah i think wren if ren's still not
here
or if he's still hanging around uh i'll
make sure you said hey
but thank you so much have a good one
come back next week we do it every
single week
all right
so that kind of works i feel like we can
still move it a little closer
because we want to get
you know this also we should probably do
all of our points here because
let's just take this circle the sweep
will duplicate it
ctrl c ctrl v and we'll move it over
because we want a bunch of different
um wires here
we'll do it again we'll grab that sweep
hold ctrl move it over
oh okay so not letting us
i think it's because we need to like
reset
um we need to reset
the dynamics or something
so maybe we have to clear it then we can
move it
and then we
grab those points again on the spline
and we set them again i'm gonna just
give it a shot here
go ahead and set it and
whoa
we got some crazy wires heck yeah
now that's cool i'm digging that
we can um give them a like a black
texture and also scale down the
thickness of these guys they're a little
intense
and we'll give them a black texture
sir pug what's good thanks for joining
do i ever use blender um you know i i
watch some tutorials from time to time
yeah i think it's good to know how to
use it so
i can tell you guys you know what i what
i would do if i was in blender
but um
yeah i think i think it'd be helpful all
right so uh
raw red what are you what are you saying
no wires on these things are super thick
started watching okay i got you you're
saying that the wires on these guys are
thick i just think for the image itself
it feels like a bit too much so i i
probably want to
duplicate these a number of times so let
me let me go
back here let me delete this let me
take off the spline dynamics we'll do
this in a second
and i want to grab all the points that
are going to be
fixed let's see
with the spline selected we'll come in
here
grab these bits and i like how it's
already hanging
all right so now we got those points
selected
i go to the model mode i should be able
to duplicate the sweep control drag
over
and i'll get it over on the other side
too
and actually it looks like there's three
rows of this stuff
i'll get it over in the middle and there
might even be like a lower section
too it looks like there is
but i don't think we really need to
worry about that right now
let's go ahead and we need to we need to
lock these guys up so i'm gonna go hair
tags
spline dynamics and just start locking
these guys up
should be able to hit
set on this and just have it
work because we pre-selected
those points in point mode before we
duplicated it
so i'm just making this as quick as i
can
air tag spline dynamics set we just got
three more it looks like two or three
more
set and last one air
spline and set and if i go back to
frame one let's see what happens
whoa
what's going on you know i just realized
i don't even need dynamics anymore
because
we kind of it's already in the shape we
want
isn't it so why go why add dynamics if
we don't need to
i'm gonna close the circles up a little
bit more
to keep it thin i don't want to draw too
much attention to these wires
it's definitely a small detail um
that's pretty sweet like i'm digging
that i'm doing that a lot
so you're saying you can't see the
transmission tower in the render that's
because it just needs
uh to render for one because it's very
pixelated
when we're just looking at like fog it
really needs to like take its time
to get up to speed here sample wise so
i'm gonna just set this to render
um 2000 frame or two thousand samples
let's put it somewhere uh 600 by 900
is fine for now let's let's maybe no
let's just do
let's double that 1200 by 1800
current frame is fine we will
save and let's do
where do we want to put this
an exr
boom all right so i'm going to set this
to render
um and hopefully it'll clear everything
up the fog will be nice and crispy it'll
look really good
and then we'll add some post effects in
photoshop
but while it renders um
[Music]
i think it's time to do the
weekly challenge we're gonna announce
the five winners
um let me set this up real quick
and i will be back in two minutes
this is just so i can use my brb screen
let me know if it's too loud if the
volume is mixed too high
and i'll fix it immediately all right
y'all
i'll see you in two seconds i'm just
gonna get this render set up
um get a drink of water and
we're gonna announce the winners of
the weekly challenge right i'll see
y'all
in like two minutes don't move all right
don't move your butts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all it's time it's time to
review
the five winners and announce the
winners of the weekly challenge the the
the challenge was uh was
what was it it was dream all right it
was a dream
all right so i got this whole new thing
for the art review stuff
let's give it a shot uh let me turn down
my freaking iso
and we'll give it a go
all right let's see if this works i hope
to god let me let me actually
go to studio mode just in case
um and if this doesn't work
it works okay all right we can we can
transition to this get off of studio
mode because we're doing it because look
at this guys we got a blank slate
and there's this is this very
complicated set of stuff here
um but hopefully this works all right
hopefully this works
i'm very excited about this so obviously
as you can see the challenge winners
they get a little cg trophy up here you
also get the challenge winner role in
the discord server so you guys can rep
that
um all the challenge winners will be
like put up towards the top
in the discord server so everyone's
gonna know who won
there's five winners all right and
because
there were i know you guys want me to do
and review
all the submissions i just don't have
time i just do not have time but
what i'm doing right now i'm gonna
announce the five winners okay
and then i'm going to go in and give out
some honorable mentions and tell you
guys why i thought that these renders
were awesome um it's not gonna be every
single one
but it'll be more than just the five i
think i got an extra 10
for y'all all right
okay so titum's like oh snap a cg trophy
i gotta step up my game now
can't tell if you've been sarcastic um
but uh you know you're you're freaking
great dude you got some solid renders
i'm sure it's all good
uh i'll send you a freaking cg trophy
on discord i don't know how it's gonna
work well i don't know
i also think too um let me double
confirm this
let me double double confirm this
that there is a prize
this week um
weekly challenge for dream yep
okay yeah so the prize this week is my
surface imperfection
pack um if you guys
don't know what that is we used some of
the surface imperfections to
light our city and to get our you know
our city look
that you can see here we're rendering
away it's going to be awesome you know
what since this is going to take a
little bit longer i might just render a
bigger image but
i'll just do that later um
okay so you guys are gonna win the
surface imperfection pack it's gonna be
a good time
let's just get right to it so the first
winner of
the uh of the weekly challenge
the dream prompt is
i believe one
dead duck
this is awesome this is absolutely
sick like i love your lighting quality
um jeez it looks it looks like
a renaissance painting the way this
thing is
lit it's so good i love the texture on
your
your ghosts um
and while going through these
submissions i really
tried to pick the winners that
that their renders read as dream
i look at it and i and i see oh this is
this has a dream theme involved that was
the first thing
does it read as like a dream right
the second obviously is um well not
obviously
the second option i'm going for the
second thing i'm looking for is
originality
um you know is this something that came
from your head that
i that i i can't really tell where it
came from maybe
um i know a lot of you guys do stuff
based off of movies and stuff but um
this feels original to me like this is
awesome this is very very cool
and third is like the quality of your
render
does it look awesome and boy this looks
awesome
freaking awesome okay so that's the
first one that's our first
winner uh mr one dead duck you are going
to be getting my service imperfection
pack
use it wisely um now
next we have a render
by i think this person's name is
industry this is
awesome i love this
so much the colors
are incredible composition
is incredible i'm such a such a fan of
this
render and it is it feels very very
dreamy to me
and the reason this speaks to me um
as very dreamy is not just because it
looks dreamy and
and it feels surreal i actually get this
weird feeling
when i close my eyes sometimes as i'm
drifting off the bed
where i feel tiny
in a huge room and then it'll switch to
like
i feel huge in a tiny room do you guys
ever get that do you guys
do you guys ever feel that i don't know
what it is i don't know if it's just me
um and it's not all the time it's just
sometimes
but i get that with this right here like
this is super cool
i'm a fan uh so industry congrats
you have won the challenge winner roll
as well as the surface imper
imperfection pack
so you can do some really cool stuff
with that i'm excited to see what you do
i know right the color it's so good
okay next up
who do we have it is
tapi ki sotoku with this render
right here so
at first i was like i don't know because
the render quality wasn't quite up to
par at least what i like you know like
compared to some of the others it's good
don't get me wrong it's a winner it just
won
um but you know like the skin shader the
hair shader
you can see the kind of like the
polygons and the bed
um or the the shirt but
this wins because
it reads as a dream so well it might be
the best one
honestly that reads as this is a dream a
very cool take on a dream
kind of state um and it
shows what the dream is it's super cool
it's like in the physical world um
the lighting the render quality is not
bad it's not bad i think it just could
be better like skin shader the hair
um the blanket you know all that kind of
stuff
but it's original i love it i think it's
so good
it's so good so congratulations to
uh tapi ki sotoku you're gonna get
the uh challenge winner roll this week
and you're also gonna get the surface
imperfection pack
all right we're on number three here
we're going on to number four
so the fourth winner is
blaster jacks with this
awesome render this feels like
so fantastical to me um
[Music]
like i just love the look of it i love
the lighting i love how lush it is
i love this landscape you have this
character who just stepped out
and into this awesome dream world um
it feels like a dream world to me feels
like that um
the render quality is fantastic the
lighting is fantastic
i dig it i really dig it um i feel like
the only thing that's missing
is just a more emphasis light wise on
the character that's it
um otherwise it's incredible so
congratulations blaster jacks you're
going to be getting
that surface imperfection pack as well
as the challenge winner roll this week
uh moin moin khan
dude thank you for the super chat you're
still waiting
on an airplane cockpit render
you mean for the weekly challenge
an airplane cockpit weekly challenge
kind of specific see we'll see well
i'mma ask you guys what y'all want to do
here we'll take a vote
but let's get to the fifth one
the fifth and final winner of this
week's weekly challenge
is tristan with this video right here
and again this was another one that i
was like on the fence about because
it's very quick it would have been cool
if it looped
like the character started falling in
bed and then it went into the universe
like that actually would have been sweet
i think slo-mo could have been a bit
more surreal
um this is definitely going for the
scary angle i get that
but after watching it over and over and
over it'd be nice to actually slow it
down a little bit
and take a take a closer look at it
but i think it's cool the reason it's a
winner is because it's an original
concept it reads as dream very clearly
and your render quality is pretty nice
so congratulations tristan
and to all five of you all for winning
this week's weekly challenge you guys
are gonna get the surface and perfection
pack
hit me up on discord or i'll hit you up
on discord one of the two
and we'll get you those packs and we'll
get you making your renders all dirty
soon enough and if you guys uh you guys
want to take a look
at that pack there's a link in the
description below
it's on gumroad it's a good time i'm
very proud of it
i think it turned out really well so um
congrats to all five winners of the
weekly challenge
guys um let's talk about a couple
runner-ups that i thought
were really really cool so let me
um let me switch over let's do it
all right so first thing let's see let's
uh
let's hide this let's start bringing
some up
mowing con you want me you want me to
make a render of an a320 cockpit
it's pretty advanced it's pretty
advanced but i will take note
i will take note right now
we'll see what we can do alright so
runner-ups guys uh copperbot
with this guy here this is super cool
i like the diner feel the water inside
is awesome it actually came with a video
i just didn't have time to prep it up
in this new format so
you know you guys can see it just go to
the submissions tab in the discord and
watch copperbot's video it's super cool
i dig it
next time if i have more time i'll try
and get the videos uploaded here
onto this new format um which should be
possible it just took a bit to set it up
for the first time but yeah very
inception i dig this one a lot
um next we have neo
knife new knife render i really like
this the color in this is super cool
i dig it so much the blue and the red
with like
i don't know you have something like
some sort of filter on top of this it
looks really cool
i dig it it's super sick um
matrix vibes for sure
so yeah i just want to give you a shout
out there
visual with this render here incredible
absolutely incredible i actually had a
dream once where
um like plants
started growing up through my feet and
like
out of my body at the same time it was
so gross it was so gross and this gives
me that feeling
um but she kind of she kind of looks
like the character
from uh shoot leon the professional
natalie portman right yeah super sick
visual your renders are always
incredible uh vehicle
this is just a nice photo like super
nice
very well rendered the black and white
makes you really choose what you're
seeing
can you read the shapes and i can read
the shapes and it looks sick
like your composition and your lighting
freaking awesome
tinum your render quality is ridiculous
dude
and this is another one with a video so
you can check the video out uh
in the submissions in the discord server
i mean it's it's a flawless render dude
i i don't have anything else to say
about it
it's absolutely incredible soulmate
yeah okay a little loud apologies
um but yeah this is this is a freaking
super solid
render here um i like this it's like the
the feeling
of uh of
like you know looping you know kind of
like that looping uh
slow run i dig that a lot i dig that a
lot
uh ronin
i really like this
cartoon look you have this cell shading
it feels very whimsical um
you know very inspiring it reminds me of
like ghibli stuff
i dig it a lot it feels very very fun
pillow fort with this i dig this a whole
lot this is a really cool concept
walking down the stairs to the end of
the dragon upside down
it would have been cool to have like
space maybe in here some stars i think
could like maybe round it out a little
bit
um but i dig that one a lot
coltrane this is sick man what an
awesome render what a what a sweet image
your colors are awesome the render
quality is awesome and you have some
really really cool textures going on
here
congrats on that man shout outs for sure
astro funk i really like your colors
here
and i like this universe above the bed i
think it's really really cool
i like it a lot and finally fruit juice
mr fruit juice this is great i really
dig it
i mean it matches your your profile
picture too
it's really cool dude i love your colors
i love the softness to it it feels
very nice like yeah your colors are sick
man
good stuff very very very good stuff
so congrats to all the winners and
everyone who came uh
as an honorable mention i thought it
would be cool to just you know
shout you guys out after all the hard
work that you put in so
um yeah let's figure out what's the next
weekly challenge going to be right now
start dropping ideas here in the chat
i'm i'm looking at you
and then we're going to come back here
we're going to we're going to
bring this image into photoshop and
you know wrap it out so
what do you all think what do you what
do you guys think about the
the weekly challenge this week what do
you guys want to work on what do you
guys want to get better at
okay landscape robots so a lot of these
we actually did
last year not to say we don't we can't
do them again
cyberpunk could be sweet cyberpunk is a
good one
colors oh colors that's i like that
wow lots of ideas dang you guys are this
is great
black and white isn't bad either
all right so right now i'm digging
oh pipes is cool okay pipes
black and white colors
and there was one other that i liked uh
cyberpunk
so i'm digging these ones right now
hmm what do you guys think
cyberpipe
people are down for cyberpunk
black and white i'm seeing man it's this
is tough
this is a tough one uh
color and pipes and
wow yeah this is this is a hard one
okay so between black and white
in color what do you guys think
between those two
all right i see a lot of color
i think color it is
all right y'all okay so everyone's
saying
giving their opinion right now i better
see y'all make some renders i want to
see some freaking renders from you guys
let's do it color is the prompt okay
um i want i want you to really pay
attention
to the color on this render okay the
challenge
is to render something with some
freaking awesome colors
i want you to look into complementary
colors
tertiary tertiary tertiary tertiary
colors um color opposites
you guys i want you to dig in and look
for some coolness
now i actually just found out of a
really cool resource
for color okay let me show you what it
is
it is a website called
coolers not not
coolers
or is it coolers io
oh my god what am i doing google how
about we just go to freaking google
and we typed in colors i think it's
colors.com yeah here we go
um let's start the generator
thanks for the sub if you're everyone's
subbing right now that's awesome
if you guys enjoy this consider
subscribing you know so you guys will be
alerted to the next ones
so i'm hitting spacebar and it's just
generating different colors
and these are really pleasing um you can
lock
certain ones if you like this one and
you like that one you can lock them
until you find something like this
yellow is cool
and you get a nice mix of colors that
you like
i like that blue and maybe we get like a
black or a white or something which you
can just
select down here
and let me do this
get something yeah like that or
something yeah and there's those are
your colors that you're gonna work with
so you can go on this website coolers.co
and and come up with some cool colors
you can cancel some of these out and
just come up with like
three and find a nice combination that
you like
but really pay attention to the colors
on this one
have a good time challenge yourself to
do that
the the prompt will be in the discord
server soon once i'm done with the
stream here but let's
lastly hop into photoshop to wrap out
our image
all right so let's open it on
up so if you guys have never done
a challenge before it's all prompted
from the discord server okay the links
in the description
you have one week to do it you have to
submit by to
uh not tomorrow you have to submit by
next
week next saturday at 9 00 a.m pacific
standard time so i can actually go
through
and like judge them and load them into
this like
you know the new uh the new art review
source and everything or scene um
[Music]
obviously no cheating no plagiarism
don't follow a tutorial and post it as a
result
that stuff is not going to go over well
all right
and this one's a little bit harder to do
that on anyway because it's colors right
so
let's do it let's uh let's get photoshop
going here
and let's open up our image that we just
made let's see oh man after this i have
to render the horizontal view
for the thumbnail okay
night city render boom here we go
cool so we actually get like a nice view
of it you can actually see
the uh the transformers here
once it's rendered properly so that's
awesome
let's go ahead and open up an image
that i always use it's actually these
like film overlays which you can get
on google just type in like film green
texture
and it's pretty large
and these i set the overlay which i
can't right now because
i'm at a 32-bit image let's go to 8-bit
and
we'll merge it and we'll set this to
exposure and gamma
maybe we'll up the exposure whoa
up the exposure just a little bit
cool then we drop in the film grain
and we'll flip it upside down because
it's a little brighter on the top
you know what no let's keep it on the
bottom and i'm gonna set that to
overlay and that gets you
a really nice kind of you know kind of
film green look here
if i turn this on and off that's very
subtle
because our images is kind of already
grainy
but it's definitely something that i
don't i don't miss out on um
[Music]
it helps out a lot get out of here
i also probably want to lift the blacks
a little bit so i'm going to
grab a little levels adjustment here
and we'll drop it down so it's just
above our image
and let's just maybe lift
let me lift the black value just a
little bit just so it's not completely
dark
and why is it not kidding oh that's
because the film green
oh it needs to be down there okay
hmm so other than that like this is
pretty sweet
already you know i don't know if we need
to do too much more
to this image like maybe
you know this is a hundred percent maybe
we just blur it just a little bit
like especially this woman here um
you could go filter blur
gaussian blur and give it just like a
blur of like
point two something very small
because there's no such thing as a
perfect crisp photo
maybe there is i'm sure there is
but
you know it just helps a little bit it
helps to take out the cg look of it
and i agree i think the power lines are
a little large and i think they could be
moved over to the right just a bit
so i'd have to go back in and you know
work on my render a little bit more but
i'm happy with this i think you guys get
the idea with this um
have fun with this effect and you know
join the discord server post it in there
show me what you guys are up to
let's keep learning let's keep growing
um i think that's it y'all
i think that's it i think we've done it
i hope to see you guys next week because
these are just going to
keep getting better throughout the year
all right um let me see you next week
it's going to be a good time
let me see the week after that so i'm a
chill for another like
you know three to five minutes hang out
with you guys if you have any questions
i'll answer them right here um
and then yeah i hope you guys enjoy your
weekend thanks for coming by i
appreciate it
i'll see you soon peace guys
i need to get some like stream friendly
music here for like
these little uh intro outro bits
what's my favorite t kyle okay so my
friend adam he just gave me a yuzu
matcha tea
that's freaking ridiculous blows my mind
uh so that's probably my favorite matcha
on its own is great too but yuzu
dude so good
fruit juice what you got what question
you got
i want to remake a photo you posted in
your website but can't download or view
them in hi-res is there a reason
so i want to use it for reference um
yeah you know i just don't want people
to rip my photos and make prints
on their own um but if you just
give me uh shoot me a message on discord
and i'll i'll get you what you need man
no worries how often do i stream i
stream every saturday
10 45 pacific standard time am
10 45 in the morning
what else we got how much do i recommend
a graphic tablet instead of a mouse dude
graphic tablet all day it's the best man
like
it saves my hand um
from getting that carpal tunnel i'm able
to just be smoother and faster it feels
more natural
the reason i got it is because i wanted
to i know that i'm going to be doing
this for the rest of my life so i want
to
promote as much longevity as possible in
my health
so that's why i got this thing it's like
400 bucks
it's a wacom intuos pro
4 tablet the medium size one it's
freaking great moin khan thanks for the
super chat
i got you with that knowledge man thanks
for coming by
thanks for hanging out yeah
what else what else
hmm when was the last time i had kimchi
like two weeks ago i got some in the
fridge though i gotta make some kimchi
fried rice
can you follow a reference image for the
contest cgm studios yeah you can follow
a reference image for the contest
definitely man that's totally fine i'm
using reference all the time
uh devin i'm glad you enjoy watching
these man that's super cool
that's super cool thanks for coming by
dja you wanna a black hole in c4d
interesting interesting i think there's
already a black hole octane tutorial out
there
i don't know if i could do much better
than that that was a good one
do i use a 4k monitor i do not
um maybe one day
am i in japan by chance i wish good god
i wish
now i'm in uh i'm in los angeles
the house we're in was uh was created by
some japanese
architects so they they put in some
stuff like this
which is super cool i like i dig this a
whole bunch
what else we got
do i know what brand the yuzu matcha is
yeah it's like it's dens t
d-e-n dens t i think it's incredible
tinum how's my film going when do you
start or did you start already i did not
start already but i will do a feature
film i know that
i just need to find the project the idea
the writer the team
um and it'll happen that's that's the
goal man that's the big goal that's the
whole reason i'm doing all this
the whole reason i'm getting good at 3d
so i can
direct a feature film and pop off 3d
shots that look real
if i need to that's the whole reason it
all comes back to the feature film
that i want to do so badly
new new fix i'm glad you found my
channel too
uh that's awesome you found out about it
on
the stuntman reacts heck yeah dude
that's awesome
thanks for joining thanks for watching
i want a drawing glove any
recommendations this is just a 10
glove on amazon that's it
there's not even a brand on it i think
i've used it so much i got wiped off
it's whatever man there it's like 10
bucks super cheap
oh architecture theme for next week that
could be cool but maybe next week
we already chose one we chose colors
this time
all right oh
nice tinum you're currently working on
your pixar inspired short that's awesome
dude
i want to do i want to do a an animated
short
maybe something this year i think that
could be sweet
y'all are the best thank you for joining
me
um yeah if you guys aren't part of the
discord community
hop on there it's an awesome time lots
of helpful people you guys are super
cool i'm very very blessed to have
such awesome um fans and have to have
built a community
of really like chill people so that's
cool
you guys are awesome keep it up keep
learning keep growing
and we're just going to get better we're
going to keep getting better so
i'm going to bounce out of here i'm
going to get some lunch i got some
oh yakodan in the fridge
it's going to be good but until
until next week i'll see you guys in the
discord server all right good luck on
the challenge
join it it's fun all right maybe
there'll be a prize
check the post in the next 20 minutes or
so
um but i'll see you guys soon have a
good one
and uh yeah have a good day
alright guys peace out